independent voters meaning those not  registered as democrats or republicans  are now by a margin that is relatively  modest leaning towards democrats rather  than republicans in the upcoming midterm  elections every metric over the last two  months has shifted in the direction of  democrats odds of keeping the house has  shifted in the direction of democrats  odds of keeping the senate although  still uh uh  not by a major margin has shifted in the  direction of democrats and now  the much  sought after independent vote is  slightly shifting over to democrats so  do i think democrats are going to clean  up in november and take the house and  senate no most likely democrats will  still lose the house but  if democrats can keep gaining at the  rate at which they've been gaining by  election day it'll be a 50-50 coin flip